LYLA FUJIWARA: It's best
practice to provide resources
for supporting all
devices, but sometimes it
might seem like you
need to make a trade off
between supporting
devices and a small APK.
Now, if you're not using
multi APK, supporting
different screen densities,
CPU architectures,
and language could account for
a pretty big chunk of your app's
APK size.
That's why we've introduced a
new publishing format called
the Android App Bundle.
It'll mean smaller
downloads for your audience
and easier artifact management
in the Play Console for you.
An app bundle is a single,
comprehensive build artifact
that you upload to Google
Play instead of an APK.
Compared to multi
APK, an app bundle
delivers smaller apps
to users and is simpler
to manage because it's
only one build artifact.
When Google Play
has your app bundle,
it uses a new process
for delivering
APKs called dynamic delivery.
Put simply, it only sends
the portions of your app
that each user needs.
Now, just using the
new app bundle format
will automatically
give your users
APKs with only the language,
screen density, and ABI
resources that they require.
And it requires no code
refactoring from you.
Building an app bundle
is just a matter
of selecting the
right build output.
When using Android
Studio, here you'll
see the option to generate
a signed app bundle.
Select Building a bundle instead
of an APK, provide your key,
choose the destination
folder, and you're done.
You'll then have your
shiny new app bundle.
You'll also need to enroll
in Google Play app signing
in the Play Console.
Google Play is essentially
generating optimized APKs
for your users, so you
need to give it the ability
to sign those APKs for you.
App bundles are supported
by Google Play right now.
The technology that play uses
to generate APKs from the bundle
is open source,
so in the future,
your app bundle will
work with other app
stores that enable support.
Bundles work for all devices.
Devices running
lollipop and higher
get the greatest size benefit
from dynamic delivery,
but pre-lollipop devices will
still get a multi APK style
APK, which is automatically
generated by Google
Play from your app bundle.
Let's go ahead and
take a closer look
at how Google Play
actually uses this bundle,
what dynamic delivery is doing,
and how users get their APKs.
In the past, you'd
upload an APK,
and then Play would then
serve that same APK.
When you upload an app bundle,
Google Play takes that bundle
and splits it into
multiple smaller
APKs known as split APKs.
The part of the app which
is always downloaded
is placed into a split
APK called the base APK.
When using a bundle,
Play automatically
makes split APKs for resources,
assets, and native libraries.
These resource
specific split APKs
are called configuration APKs.
Let's take a look at an example.
I'm an English speaking
user on a Pixel 2
XL with 560 DPI resolution
running on an ARM 64 processor.
If I install your
app, dynamic delivery
will find just the split APKs
that I specifically need.
These split APKs will
be delivered down
to compatible
devices that behave
like a single customized APK
that's optimized for my device.
For earlier devices,
dynamic delivery
will send out a multi APK
with research appropriate ABI
and density resources.
With the introduction
of the Android app
bundle and dynamic
delivery, we're
allowing for
automatically smaller apps
and a smoother
deployment process.
In addition, the
app bundle format
also introduces dynamic
features, at least in beta.
Dynamic features allow you to
modularize specific features
and then deliver them
to your users on demand.
For more information,
check out the links below.
If you're curious about
bundlefying your app,
the best place to get started
is g.co/andriodappbundle.
Happy coding.